[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH JESSOP: Norwegian theorist Johann Galtung
developed a three-layered understanding of violence
that represents how a confluence of factors
merge, in particular historical moments, to shape the conditions
for the promotion of violence.
Direct violence is what we normally think of when we think about violence.
It represents behaviors that serve to threaten life itself,
and or to diminish one's capacity to meet
basic human needs, such as killing, maiming, bullying, sexual assault,
and emotional manipulation.
Structural violence represents the systematic ways
in which some groups are hindered from equal access
to opportunities to goods and services that enable
the fulfillment of basic human needs.
These can be formal, as in legal structures
that enforce marginalization, such as apartheid in South Africa.
Or they could be informal but common practices,
such as limited access to education or health care for marginalized groups.
Cultural violence represents the existence
of prevailing or prominent social norms that
make direct and structural violence seem natural or right,
or at least acceptable.
For example, the belief that Africans are primitive and intellectually
inferior to Caucasians gave sanction to the African slave trade.
Galtung's understanding of cultural violence
helps explain how prominent beliefs can become so embedded in a given culture
that they function as absolute and inevitable, and are
reproduced uncritically across generations.
These three forms of violence are interrelated and mutually reinforcing,
and understanding them better is crucial for the pursuit of a broader
and deeper peace.